And the answer is that these two equations, y equals 5x and y equals 12 minus
3x, are the only two equations for which the slope can be found from the
coefficient of the term with an x to the first power in it. The equations here
which don't just make straight lines when we graph them, which, as we'll learn
later on in the course, are those that have factors of x combined with other
things besides constants. So, those would include this first equation, this very
long, not very nice equation, this one and this one definitely don't have this
property. In fact right now, we have no idea how to talk about the slope of line
that isn't just a straight line. If we have some sort of funky curve, how can we
talk about the direction that it's pointing? It's pointing in different
directions at all these different points. So, we can rule all of those answers
phases out. We'll talk more about the slopes of these four remaining equations
in just a second.